sí
ahora que ya estás familiarizado con los
paquetes de acabados es hora de trabajar
para comenzar empecemos simplificando el
problema
una pierna de dinosaurio es
esencialmente un cilindro con garras
ignoremos las garras por el momento y si
desenvolvemos el cilindro
obtenemos un rectángulo plano un plano
en 2d podríamos trabajar en un plano y
después doblarlo para ponerlo a prueba
pensamos en la geometría de nuestras
líneas camas cada escama es una figura
irregular y todas juntas tienen que
encajar como un rompecabezas en pixar
usamos un truco genial para generar este
tipo de patrones se conoce como el
diagrama de voronoi se basa en un patrón
que vemos en todos lados en la
naturaleza desde las manchas de las
jirafas hasta las grietas que se forman
cuando se seca el lodo y podemos
explicar las matemáticas de los
diagramas de voronoi con burbujas si
llenamos un contenedor de burbujas así
se aplastan entre sí y obtenemos ese
mismo patrón que depende de donde se
tocan las burbujas pensemos en la
geometría que hay aquí empecemos
colocando unos cuantos puntos en el
plano no importa donde imaginé que son
burbujas pequeñas llamémosles zonas
después las agrandamos eventualmente
burbujas vecinas chocarán en un solo
punto y mientras se expanden se forman
una línea
se están aplastando dibujamos nuestras
líneas en estas fronteras de las
burbujas y observa qué pasa cuándo
hacemos esto con muchas son las
esparcidas obtenemos este patrón de
rompecabezas irregular tienes un patrón
de voronoi o sea un diagrama de voronoi
llamaremos a cada una de estas regiones
una celda entonces tenemos zonas y
celdas y hay unas propiedades muy
interesantes aquí el borde de cada celda
siempre tiene la misma distancia a las
dos zonas más cercanas y en cada tres
líneas que se encuentran obtenemos lo
que llamamos vértice que también aquí
vista de las tres zonas más cercanas
todas gracias al increíble poder de las
burbuja no de las matemáticas hagamos
una pausa y veamos si entiendes cómo
dibujar estos patrones de voronoi el
siguiente ejercicio te ayudará a pensar
cómo funcionan estos es un buen momento
para tomar lápiz y papel porque recuerda
garabatear es muy útil
tienes alguna buena historia sobre
diagramas de voronoi si en los
increíbles teníamos un pastel hermoso
hecho para votar
y le iba a dar una gran mordida y estaba
lleno de hermosas burbujas y la
cobertura era brillosa y húmeda
simplemente maravillosa y luego la
historia cambió un poco y la escena
terminó ocurriendo en la noche entonces
jamás podrás ver esas hermosas burbujas
devorando hoy suena delicioso